- Early helicopter life.
Matt Higgins and AJV.
- Stop.
- Stop. That's gonna make
me put you on it twice.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Hold You Down"
by Aqua Stone Throne)
- [Gary] I just
think it's worth the risk.
Okay.
I don't care if you're somebody
that uses big data and you're
good at synthesizing it.
I don't care if you're the
greatest natural talent like
I am and you just live
life and it just comes to you.
I just don't care
what your process is.
It's just get me to
the insights, right?
Get me to the thing, right?
To me, I don't know what brand
strategy you know it's Karen
27-year-old she has two kids or
it's a it's the manifesto from
the brand or if
it's like find it,
here's what I know.
Every piece of business needs
us to find the white space.
The problem with either/or
or anything we
come up with is the
humans are to break it.
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- So let's start with that.
Let's start that no matter what
we decide here it will not work
and I'm being dead serious.
What I mean by that is
it's what human beings do.
It's what they do.
Depending on their
level of ego and pride,
humility and thought like
teamwork so I think my job at
the top of the sphere
is to give thought to
things that position
less friction, not more.
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- And I'm not saying having an
overarching idea is that but
that is the only
filter I'm going through.
Awesome, thank you guys.
That helped me.
- [Tyler] I just
sent myself a note.
- [Chris] That progression
we're always talking about.
Can you think of any brands off
the top of your head that have
just died out because--
- [Gary] Radio to television?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] The first wave.
- [Alex] Or TV to phone
or whatever that looks like.
- TV to phone.
Well, you know what?
You can say it's happening now.
("Break" by JMKM)
Cool.
- [Chris] Thank you.
- Not gonna be a lot.
You're gonna show
that but if you can,
might want to be able.
Guys, we're gonna play music
over what just happened but it
was fucking brilliant.
("Break" by JMKM)
Okay, well listen,
then I'll be frank with you,
if that's the case
then that's what I'll do.
So I'm gonna go to
Alan's office right now.
Literally walk
out with that in mind.
- [DRock] How are you?
- [Gary] 'Sup stranger?
Guys, it's DRock.
(group laughter)
He does other things.
- I do.
- [Gary] How was
your day yesterday?
- It was great.
- What's going
on with the episode?
- [Man] Loved both
ideas and they're like
can this extend into print?
- [Gary] Of course.
Everything can
extend into everything.
- [Man] Well, of course.
And if it can, show us both
ideas in print and then that'll
help us decide which one.
- [Gary] I see. Okay, good.
- [Man 2] How big is this idea?
(crosstalk)
- [Gary] Can you do me a favor?
Can you tell them
that they should really,
really consider running both in
print on Facebook against the
actual consumers that they want
to buy it and read the quant and
qual data against it?
Just tell them that as well.
Tell them I walked
in and said this.
Yes, this do your thing.
Have you thought about how smart
it would be to spend $50,000 to
have these two
pictures $25,000 media spend,
we don't have to do it.
I don't even know what their
fucking MSA is like we just want
to tell them what
to plan against.
I don't know, you know, 27 to
42-year-old moms with families
and run them and then read the
quant and qual data because that
would also give them a data
point of the actual end consumer
for this debate.
Three seconds left
should say to watch the
whole thing go to Facebook.com.
- [Man] We have for
more go to (censored).com.
- [Gary] Nope.
Three seconds take over
the whole fucking thing,
no half-pregnant.
- [Man] No, it's a full on.
- [Gary] Respect.
People don't
want to go to brand.
You'll lose 80 to 90% of the
thing because nobody want to go
to brand's website but they'll
go to Facebook and I actually
think the way to do it is to
say go to Facebook and search
(censored) and you guys just
have to see how it's coming up.
Yeah, so just jumped in.
We've got a huge new
client so I jumped in.
Were you filming it?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- Nice job.
Make sure you
blur out the stuff.
Huge new client so
the team's excited, I'm excited.
Big new brand in the building.
Big new holding
company in the building.
Key moments this is where I like
to come in and sprinkle I think
managers and CEOs do really poor
job and they want to bake a cake
and put the icing on and the
sprinkles and the cherry and
that's called micromanaging.
It's just a bad idea.
To me, I want to be in
the cherry business, right?
Like, I believe in my team.
Go make the cake.
Go make the icing.
Go make the sprinkles.
I'm just gonna put the greatest
fucking cherry you've ever seen
on that cake.
That's good.
- Read a book called "Crush It!"
- [Gary] How'd you
get it? Do you know?
- [Man 2] My dad was into it.
My dad's the one, my
dad is a huge mentor to me.
Much like your dad is to
you and he's the one who
kind of told me about it.
I was like, "Dad, I'm
not really into reading."
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I hate to read.
- [Gary] Yeah, me too.
- It's a huge challenge for me.
- [Gary] To me, the
things I think most about are
number 1, 2, 3 and 4 is to
build self-esteem.
So my belief is that
self-esteem is the only drug
that combats the world.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I genuinely that.
- [Mark] That's powerful.
- In parallel,
it's imperative that
you don't build
fake self-esteem.
- [Mark] Right.
- Self-esteem can't be
manufactured through rewarding
non-rewarding events.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- If you--
- [Man 2] Participation
trophies.
- Correct.
You can't come in eighth place
in the race in school and then
get prized for that
because that is not real life.
- [Mark] Mhmmm.
- However Xander, for example,
this weekend when Max got hurt,
his nephew, stopped what he was
doing and came over and showed
amazing empathy for a
four-year-old that has become
now the thing I've talked
to him about for two days.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- That he's incredible.
That you have
such a great heart.
- [Mark] Right.
- To me you triple down,
this is by the way,
this is me being a
byproduct of being what
I think perfectly parented.
This is what my mom did.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- My mom over exaggerated
my natural goodness
as a person to
make me believe it was
like the most important thing.
- [Mark] Yeah, mhmmm.
- And she never gave me third
place trophies and when I lost,
I lost and she made me realize
there were repercussions in life
so when I got bad grades even
though she knew I was in a very
special, I was literally
punished subconsciously I knew
that it wasn't the most
important thing in the world but
I do like that she punished me
and didn't let me completely
disrespect the system.
But she never let it
hurt my confidence. Right?
She played it very smart and
there is something interesting
my parents did.
At 14 they said look, tough guy
you not gonna be a student
means you're gonna work.
And so that means
you're gonna start working now.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And so, I do think one of
the great things my parents did,
I think a lot of parents should
think about this is if you don't
have a student, even if they're
an artist and want to sing and
paint, you need to figure out
establish massive work ethic
because the only thing that's
controllable for somebody who's
gonna bet on themselves
in life is their work ethic.
Their talent, you
can get it better.
You can lift more, right?
You can get better
at things but some,
my calves and ass
aren't naturally the same
as everybody else's.
There are people that are
naturally like I don't like my
chest is never gonna be as big
as I necessarily want it 'cause
there's certain
things that are, right?
But meanwhile like I'll
sell you back the hat you're
wearing right now.
- [Mark] Right.
- I will and so I think that,
I think it's important to teach
work ethic because work ethic
is the only thing that maximizes
what you naturally
have and that's really
the best you can ask for.
I mean this is my
new favorite office.
(group laughter)
- [Juice] How's it going? Juice.
- [Gary] Juice,
how are you, man?
- [Man 3] How's it going?
We've actually met before.
- [Gary] Remind me.
- Houston.
- Oh my God, yes.
- I was like hey
man I'm not here for,
I just want to say hi--
- Yes.
- I'll see you at
the end of the month.
- I remember, I remember.
- I wanted to
apologize to you really fast.
When I met you, I like hit your
shoulder in a weird way
and I hit your throat.
I have a meting with you
later this month with Alex...
- Yeah.
- So I'm sorry about that.
- What's amazing, I'm so
amazingly strong now that
I don't remember that.
My big thing right now is
Facebook long form videos,
influencers on Instagram
and what I would
call hacking culture.
Anything that can
penetrate and create noise in
a million different things.
That can mean a million
different things for my personal
brand, not my
brands and other things,
that means that I genuinely
believe that hip-hop is
the seed of our culture.
I just genuinely believe that
and I think it's a good use of
my time especially when I'm
lucky enough to have somebody
like Mike Boyd in my life.
Right, where he just generally
has a great track record and
course DRock and these guys are
always looking at Spotify and
SoundCloud and
like every youngster,
you know, spends time trying to
find new artists and different
stuff like of that nature.
I just play the same
Lionel Richie song over and
over like whatever.
People love discovery but
I am very fascinated by what's
happening in the cross-section
of the two
places you're playing.
My dream to give you as much
value right now as possible so
that when you do
become massive you're like
GaryVee was always there.
I mean it's not
super complicated.
It's that truly basic for me.
- Let me hop in the coupe,
get a shot of the goose
at the top of the booth.
Pigs in a pass, top knot, listen
for another second to bite pull
the Juice for the haters
who got it you blowing your
race by the thousand.
Had all these bites with me
that get paid by the ounce.
Unless I've been paid I'm gonna
lay that shit down like blaugh,
how you like me now?
Said pretty can you pack
'nother weight by the pound,
used to be light but that
shit's overrated and I'm fat.
Fucking the shit that he's
gaining weight way down there,
way over there.
Like outside.
Yo, shout out GaryVee baby.
Much love to
everybody watching this.
Shout out to you.
- [Gary] What's up my man?
- [Tank] What's happening?
How are ya?
- [Gary] Good, man.
How are you?
- George, nice to meet you.
- It's a pleasure.
- Tank.
- [Gary] Tank, I love it.
I'll call you whatever you want.
Fuck, man, I'll
call you whatever you
want me to call you.
(group laughter)
- I've always loved comedy.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I did stand-up which was--
- [Gary] Good for you.
- great and terrible.
Stand-up taught me
that I could do anything.
- [Gary] 100%.
- Like doing stand-up and
then talking to a girl was like,
bro, stand-up was the hardest
thing I've ever did in my life.
- [Gary] 100%, 100%.
- So any sales
situation I found myself in--
- [Gary] It's nothing.
- It's like nothing, yeah.
These people
don't have to laugh,
they just have to give me money.
It's not a big deal.
- [Gary] 100%.
- But the problem with stand-up
is I was sitting on the jokes
for like a week, two weeks,
a month until I could get to a
microphone so the
energy would just die.
So when memes happened
I was like this is sick.
I can make a joke,
find a picture,
make a joke,
get it out to people,
get feedback and go from
there on to the next thing.
So for somebody like me who's
always going memes right timing,
whatever,--
- [Gary] Of course.
- it's just been good.
But my Instagram Tank.Sinatra is
just taken off in a way that's
been so rewarding.
- (laughs) That's so awesome.
- It's crazy. It really is.
- How many you at now?
- 850. 850,000.
- Amazing.
How often are you
showing your face on
the Tank.Sinatra account?
- [Tank] On a story,
pretty regularly.
- How about on the posts?
- [Tank] On the posts,
like once a month,
maybe, max.
- Change it.
- [Tank] Yeah.
- Tomorrow. Here's how I, ready?
Ready?
- [Tank] Yeah.
- Ready?
- Minimum, stick with me.
- [Tank] Go ahead.
- Minimum--
- [Tank] Yeah,
- minimum, like you're
much bigger than me but
I'm not gonna let
you get away with it.
(Tank laughs)
Minimum--
- [Tank] Tell me what to do.
- once a week.
Minimum.
- [Tank] Okay, so--
- Fuck.
How many posts a
day are you doing?
- [Tank] A lot,
like at least six.
- Yeah, I would tell you
that if I could help it,--
- [Tank] Yeah.
- I would have you do
it once every two days.
- [Tank] Yeah.
- And you know what I would do?
Straight to face video
and I would just have
you do your thing.
- [Tank] Yeah.
- If you can
actually do stand-up,--
- [Tank] Yeah.
- fucking do it.
Straight to the face.
Like you got,
you've got it, man.
- [Tank] You like my face.
- Yeah.
(group laughter)
I like it. It's a look, right?
- [Tank] I use some in like
memes and those go over well.
- Dude, listen to me.
Let me tell you what doesn't go
away if your account went away.
The memories of you.
- [Tank] Yeah.
- [Gary] You can look
like every other fucking page.
- I know. I used to post
more selfies and I got so,
I was like, you know what?
Fuck these people.
I'm sure you deal with it.
There's the negativity.
You don't?
- [Gary] I don't give a fuck.
I, sure, I read every comment.
- [Tank] So I say that,
I say I don't give a fuck--
- But you do!
- [Tank] but I do a little bit.
- But guess what? Me too.
- [Tank] So what do you do?
- Not give a fuck.
(group laughter)
- [Tank] Like you
just don't give a fuck.
- No, I do, I do
but then I don't.
It's 51/49.
- [Tank] Dude, it's
just so aggravating.
- I'm empathetic.
- [Tank] Yes, sometimes.
- Do you understand that
I actually feel bad for them?
- [Tank] I do too sometimes.
- And I do 100% of the time.
- [Tank] Like
send me your address.
- Yeah, I'm gonna
beat, yeah, listen,
if I look like you I'd probably
beat up some people too.
Look, punchline is very
simple. I actually feel bad.
- [Tank] Yeah.
- You're in a place in your life
where you have pain and you're
taking it out on me
because in this moment you deem
that I have happiness.
I feel bad.
- [Tank] Yeah.
It's all good bro.
- Thank you, bro.
I appreciate it.
(group laughter)
Yo, if you're not following
the Tank you're making
a fucking huge mistake.
- Fuckin' up.
- I'll fuck you up.
(group laughter)
- He may want to
bring in her people.
He may want to audit everybody.
We got to think
about all those things.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- If people
understood the money,
the happiness, the fame, if
people really understood what
I was doing, they
wouldn't believe it.
That's why I actually
spend no time on it.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] I'd lose.
I'd lose because you
think I'd been trying to
sell you something.
It's only because I'm
playing such a long game.
- [Woman 2] Right.
- [Gary] Longer
than anybody actually,
I fantasize of
being 73. You know?
And having the
body of work, you know?
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] So, I understand and
that's where that was going.
- [Woman 2] Okay.
(indistinct chatter)
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Woman 3] You're welcome.
- [Man 2] Oh wow.
Oh! (laughs) 'Sup, man?
- You know it's full time.
- [Man 3] What up?
- [Ryan] You can't hide from--
- [Gary] Dude, thank
you so much for your note.
That was very sweet of you.
- [Man 4] I always
wanted to be on the DailyVee.
- You're on. Smile.
- [Man 2] You're on.
- [Man 4] What? No.
- Right there, smile.
You said you missed me.
That was very nice.
- [Man 4] You didn't
respond. I thought you--
- I know but I absorbed it.
- [Ryan] I thought you were
going to do a cancellation.
I can't believe this.
- I'm really excited.
There's literally
only one reason I'm here.
The singular reason I'm here
is I'm gonna take a selfie with
this guy and get him so
many Instagram followers.
- This guy, you remember
he did this on Snapchat?
- Yes. Yes, but ready?
(crosstalk and
group laughter)
Dude, honestly, it's
crazy what's going on.
- [Ryan] I'll be honest,
I like the content a lot lately.
- [Gary] I appreciate it.
I'll tell you why you like it,
because even when I first got to
know you and when we met
at New House or whatever.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- People that like
it are people that like,
I actually think it's strategy
disguised in motivation.
Like I think the reason people
actually get results from me and
not from everybody else
is yeah, I'm very rah-rah.
It's just in me.
It's just who I am but
I actually build businesses.
This is my side hustle.
I know what the fuck I'm talking
about and like the people that
are smart and they watch what
I'm doing more so than like get
pumped like you
only live once, yes,
you only live once but if you
actually understand why I'm
doing it, how I'm doing it.
- [Ryan] You're gonna die.
- I love that one by the way.
- [Ryan] It is good.
- It's my favorite
'cause it was so improv.
She like scared me for a, she
like rolled up on me in the car
and like uh.
- [Ryan] You're gonna die.
- It was such a...
- Three words to give
me inspiration for any day
I'm feelin' down.
- [Gary] Three words?
- Three words.
- [Gary] You're gonna die.
- Wait, wait, wait,
Tyler, say something.
- [Other Tyler] Something.
- How long's your Snapchat?
- [Man 5] The food,
I enjoy the food.
I enjoy the atmosphere.
("Break" by JMKM)